- [Tutor] Let's do a little bit
of a review of potential energy
and especially gravitational
potential energy,
because in this video,
we're going to get a
little bit more precise.
So let's say that I have an object here,
it has a mass of M
and I were to change its position
in the vertical direction,
we're assuming that we are on Earth,
where the gravitational field is G
and we have a change in the
vertical direction of delta y,
so this is its new position,
the object of mass, M,
so what is its change in
gravitational potential energy?
Well, we have seen this before,
our change in potential
energy, due to gravity
is going to be the mass of our object
times the gravitational field
times our change in position
in the vertical direction.
Now this is all good, but
there's a couple of things,
that we can get a little bit more precise,
that we can think about in this video,
one is we assumed a
constant gravitational field
and that's fine if we're
near the surface of a planet
and we also are just doing
everything on a relative basis,
but is there a way to come
up with an absolute number
on what is the gravitational
potential energy?
Well, to think about that,
let's just go back to
Newton's Law of Gravity,
Newton's Law of Gravity tells
us that if I have two objects,
so this object has mass, M1,
this object has mass, M2
and the distance between
their center of masses is r,
that the magnitude of the force of gravity
and if the force of gravity's
acting in this direction on that object,
it would have an equal
and opposite direction
on that object right over there,
so the magnitude of the force of gravity
is going to be equal to
the gravitational constant
times the product of
the two objects' masses
divided by the radius squared
or another way to think about it,
if we wanna know the
gravitational field created by M2,
well then you would just
divide both sides by M1,
so if you divide both sides by M1,
you get that the gravitational field
actually isn't constant,
it is equal to the gravitational constant
times, these cancel out, M2,
the mass of the object generating
the gravitational field
divided by r squared
and so this can actually help us
come up with an absolute formula
for gravitational potential energy.
We can say that gravitational
potential energy
and this is typically denoted
with a capital G over here
is equal to, let's say
the mass of the object
and let's just call that M1,
times the gravitational field,
so that's G times the mass of
the object creating the field
divided by r squared
times the height that this is
above the center of mass of the object
generating the gravitational field,
well, what's that?
Well, if this was Earth,
you would view r as,
well, how far am I above
the center of mass of Earth?
And so you would multiply that times r,
times r
and so this r and one of
the rs in the r squared
will cancel out, so that will just go away
and then this will just become an r
and now one thing to think about
is what should the potential energy be
as r goes to infinity?
Well, what is the gravitational
field as we go to infinity,
as r gets really, really, really large?
Well, as r gets really,
really, really large,
the gravitational field goes to zero,
but at the same time,
the further you get away,
the higher the potential
energy you should have
and so the way that
we've thought about this
is we say, hey look, let's
just put a negative out front,
you could just put it right over here
and then it all works out,
the gravitational potential energies
are always gonna be negative,
but they get less negative,
the further out you get to
and at infinity, it gets to zero.
So let me rewrite this.
The potential energy, due to gravity
can be written as the negative
of the gravitational constant
times the mass of the first object
time the mass of the
second object divided by r
and you can see this looks an awful lot
like Newton's Law of Gravity,
what the difference is,
we have a negative in front
of the gravitational constant,
instead of dividing by r
squared, we only divide by r,
but this is really, really,
really valuable now,
because now we have an absolute sense
of what gravitational potential energy is
and it meets all the properties we need,
it would still meet this idea
that the further you get away,
you will have an increase in
gravitational potential energy,
because it's going to
become less negative,
but at the same time
as you go to infinity,
as r gets infinitely far,
your potential energy is
going to approach zero.
So I will leave you there,
in future videos, we will apply this.